boy you know imma win I do here we go
again I give myself just six months to
prove that I can create a sustainable
business I understand that this is a
prison but I'm finding incredibly
difficult to get the prisoners out of
their cells and working because of the
prison authorities stringent rules and
regulations I think part of their
problem they're so short-staffed and so
for them to keep the peace and for the
more time you spend in yourself makes
their life easier
so they don't want you out you go other
remembers these guys are here for
reasons pace can it can erupt it can go
and sometimes it's over the slightest
thing and we've got to keep that under
control I'll be coming everything my
life like a mug what we used to set up
in a couple of months or two years at
that more I might meet finger look
myself then what in focused and over
here prison doctors people trying people
change their self prison ductwork prison
mark mopping don't come on okay let's
hit an artery others do if I call hair
to do go no one needs to work no one
needs to come and commit the system
screwed here that's the issues the
governor edit uhlet wants me to get the
prisoners grafting but he admits the
prison system doesn't make it easy
with things that were very number of
reasons being in a prison is a lot of
things being working on the outside but
it will to get through you've got to get
to get through you've got security
systems with routines bus officials
themselves reasons as are in jail are
probably the same reasons they've got
jobs in the first place
come in guys let's go I'm under no
illusions this lot are no angels before
they're ready to produce lunches to sell
outside prison my system gee and I need
to finish their kitchen training
everybody listen just focus okay
I want these chickens absolutely perfect
yeah a few weeks ago they couldn't even
scramble an egg today we're cooking
chicken Kiev's from scratch but not
everyone in Brixton prison appears to be
taking our project as seriously as I'd
like yesterday
repeat offender test for Jones is
unhappy with his treatment by the
officers on the wing laughs again shower
six o'clock because if you ask your
full-time worker you get shower at six
o'clock and I haven't had a shower for a
couple of days now
grimy for who's who's not letting you
guess all the senior officer of the wing
he's saying where every funnel gray so
we're not actually working so I was
there when Officer Tony the same class
does not it's amazing but it is work I
need to know that just
that's ridiculous yeah it's not that
anyone working on this prisoner gets a
special time slot to go and take a
shower after working but they're saying
it's not work you're having fun here not
all right
I thought the officer be in support of
them but no it on the opposite way has
to be x-rayed I'm going through to give
a flower no other favors over kinder
eggs in it
are you going else oh yeah however when
you have them [ __ ] you